[Background voices]
JIM FLAHERTY >> Okay, I'm Jim Flaherty. I'm
the Minister of Finance in Canada. Here at
Davos I'm having a large number of discussions
about a very important issue this year and
that is the state of the economy, um-the economy
in the world, making sure that we-that we
preserve strength in the economy so that we
can deal with the other important issues that
we have concerning the environment, demographics,
and the poorest one billion people in the
world-many of them in subSaharan Africa. All
of these issues that we do need to deal with
over time but can be dealt with only with
a strong base around the world. So, we have
these challenges right now on the economic
front that we are addressing and it's important
in terms of our ability to move forward on
the broader range of issues. The foundation
must be solid in order to do that and we are
making some progress in our understanding
of those issues here at Davos. Thanks.